Two functions, f and
g, are described below.
Which of these statements
about f and g is true?
So they defined
function f as kind
of a traditional linear
equation right over here.
And this right over here is g.
So this right over
here is g of x.
And that also looks
like a linear function.
We see it's a kind of a
downward sloping line.
So let's look at our choices
and see which of these are true.
f and g are both increasing, and
f is increasing faster than g.
Well, when I look at g--
Well, first of all, g
is definitely decreasing.
So we already know
that that's false.
And f is also decreasing.
We see here it has
a negative slope.
Every time we move forward
3 in the x direction,
we're going to move down 7
in the vertical direction.
So neither of these
are increasing
so that's definitely not right.
f and g are both increasing.
Well, that's
definitely not right.
So we know that both f
and g are decreasing.
So this first choice says
they're both decreasing, and g
is decreasing faster than f.
So let's see what
the slope on g is.
So the slope on g is every time
we move 1 in the x direction,
positive 1 in the
x direction, we
move down 2 in the y direction.
So for g of x, if we were
to write our change in y
over our change in x-- which
is our slope-- our change in y
over change in x, when we
move one in the x direction,
positive 1 in the
x direction, we
move down 2 in the y direction.
So our change in y over
change in x is negative 2.
So g has a slope of negative 2.
f has a slope of negative 7/3.
Negative 7/3 is the same
thing as negative 2 and 1/3.
So f's slope is more negative.
So it is decreasing faster.
So g is not decreasing faster
than f. f is decreasing faster
than g.
So this is not right.
And then we have this choice--
f and g are both decreasing,
and f is decreasing
faster than g.
This is right, right over here.
We have this last choice-- g is
increasing but f is decreasing.
We know that's not true.
g is actually decreasing.